so today we're going to look at two of
the games that I played last week you
guys are lucky you're the luckiest I
haven't played a slow chess tournament
in six months because I was busy very
busy okay also I was let out for good
behavior anyway so I played a turn then
last weekend after changing my mind five
times I won the AL Howlett award right
at least you got that job that's about
it okay and I actually decided to play
after the tournament started so in round
one I didn't play and I started playing
around - okay this game was played in
round three but it was my second game
because I didn't play round one he said
that works okay and I was white against
my student Matthew Larson when I started
teaching Matthew Larson his reading was
11:50 now his reading is 500 terrible no
I'm half kidding okay so his reading now
is 23 20 is that higher than you that's
higher than all of you put together and
it's higher than all of our audience at
home put together you guys at home were
terrible okay so playing Matthew Larson
I'm white now I have to explain this
game to you because you guys don't
understand when this game was being
played a more important game was being
played Michigan Ohio State football who
remembers who won that game you who won
close also close Ohio State Ohio State
no okay
now Ohio State Michigan was a very close
game at halftime and I watched the first
half like all of you and then when the
second half started I had to play my
game you understand so we played really
boring
see how boring this is are you falling
asleep and then in this position I offer
to draw and then if he takes the draw
I'd go watch Michigan Ohio State
did my opponent take the draw he's
playing a grandmaster and he's only 2300
my reign is 2600 and he's black and I'm
white so do you think he took the draw
no because he's my student
my students aren't allowed to take draws
and he's the only one who listens and he
played Bishop e7 no draw now this was
lucky for two reasons
one is I won the game that's better than
drawing and second is I didn't want to
see the second half of the chigan Ohio
State because I was rooting for Michigan
I'm from Michigan and Ohio State scored
like 800 points and this again didn't
score so I would have been watching and
crying because Michigan got crushed
instead I was watching my own game my
opponent was crying now you're going to
watch and since I'm lecturing you're
going to cry okay so we developed all of
our pieces in castled just like you do
right now okay so my opponent played
aged six because his bishop doesn't have
a lot of squares to go to if I play some
move like Knight H for attacking his
Bishop so he played h6 and now his
Bishop can escape if I attack it
something Lulu should learn right her
bishops are always getting trapped if we
knew who this person was we could tell
her right Lulu okay so h6 now I played
in the center because I said so
95 now raise your hand if you know what
Barney chess is thank you close the door
he would say I take you you take me
you're the worst player in history
okay and then he went here so we didn't
take anything else
however after Bishop to d3 we did more
Barney chess he took and I took okay now
did my opponent take the free pawn on e5
why not
you with the right answer it's not free
because then I would take your night
okay so he played a five and I play
Queen G for attacking on the Kings side
and he cancelled because you should
Castle okay now I want to checkmate my
opponent but we're not playing bughouse
we're playing bughouse I could put a
knight here I could put something here
and that I would checkmate them but all
these pieces aren't really helping me
checkmate them okay so I played an
attacking move to get more stuff towards
his King what did I do you at home
incorrect well they were wrong what do
you want now it's too hard for this
class you incorrect right the correct
answer is f4r our attack now my rook I
can do a rook lift if jenshaw howdy was
here she would approve and I can push my
pawn to f6 now some of you are like
you're not going to push your pawn to f6
he won't let you that's what you think
okay it actually took me two more moves
again my pawn to have six okay now he
surprised me he played a rook e8
because he wanted to put something on f8
like a knight or a bishop
so I played f5 and he did what I said he
would do and then I played f6 that's
pretty good attack right then he played
g6 now it's all blocked up I need more
pieces to get it his King more
professional athletes always wanting
more
so I played Knight f3 get more pieces
towards his King he played Queen b6 but
I forgot why why did he play Queen b6
hey you're correct at home that's the
first one you ever got right in my
lectures you incorrect you
hey you through your voice pretty good
good job yes except for one thing that's
not a bishop that's a pawn yeah also you
were you were correct are you feeling
all right somebody gave him some
medicine okay so did I give my pawn away
with check and lose this pawn too if I
did I would have to change my name to
Rick oh you know Rick yeah you I'm
talking about all right man I played
Rick four or five games today so my
lecture is not going to be the high
quality because pieces hanging
everywhere all right so I played Bishop
to d4 attacking his queen unfortunately
he saw it because he's rated 2,300 so he
played the obvious move yeah what's the
obvious move whoo Queen b3 losing his
queen what do you Rick is your name Rick
now yeah you but then he might win my
bishop I want to lose my bishop so
that's what happened okay
now the reason I played Bishop d4 was
sort of sneaky in this position my
bishops not really getting it is King
because I have all these pawns in the
way however if I could put my bishop on
this diagonal and then I could play like
Queen h4 or queen h3 then my bishop
could get them
so I played Bishop d4 and then I put my
bishop on that diagonal I'm going to go
here and I'm going to come get him
that's the plan
nice plans don't work okay he played a
four and I have a very famous saying
which you all know if it's free then
it's for me so I took it
most of you would play rook takes a four
and if you did I would send you back to
the one o'clock class because that's
where you belong
okay because then I would play queen
takes rook and you'd say oh no Queens
move sideways okay so instead he did a
fork but little did he realize I've seen
a lot of Forks in my life Matt Larson on
the other hand weighs about 115 hasn't
seen a lot of Forks yeah you know what
I'm saying you hear me talking yeah yeah
I've seen a lot of Forks
he played Queen a six now I saw the
original Star Wars movie when it was in
the theater when none of you were born
for thirty years yet 1978 and or 77
depending on your point of view okay
and when I saw that movie I learned a
lot about chess you know what I learned
use the forks okay so he's forking my
two pawns using the force and I played
rugby one defending my pawn did he take
it anyway now he took another one okay
now we're going to vote you can vote for
trading Queens not trading Queens or Pat
Buchanan who votes white should white
should trade Queens raise your hand who
votes white should not trade Queens what
it's somebody you vote for by accident
all right so most of you voted for not
trading Queens and Pat Buchanan was
second which is correct because you
should not trade Queens when you're
checkmating your opponent then you won't
track mate them with you what well then
you go to the one o'clock class then you
belong okay so I played efore for
obvious reasons number one I'm not
trading Queens and number two as I told
you three minutes ago but you forgot
because you were eating pie why are we
eating pie because it was 3.14 minutes
ago I wanted to play Bishop to this
diagonal and take this pawn but this
pawn was in the way so I got him out of
the way now he made the losing
move why is it good to play the losing
move who knows why why is it good to
play the losing move that's right he was
playing me so that's good if you play
the losing move not so good
unless you're playing me that's okay and
I wanted to play bishop here and take
his pawn and he was like sure he
attacked my bishop and forced it to go
there now I'm going to show you
something really now I'm going to show
you something really tricky remember no
talking that let's say he doesn't make
any move at all how about here
yuck that doesn't do anything now if I
play Bishop here with that idea I was
telling you about okay
now he hasn't moved it so tricky I can't
even show you because you'll just start
crying and then everybody get upset and
then people at home will start crying
and their tvs will stop working they'll
just be terrible he has the move Knight
takes e5 attacking my queen some of you
are confused because because y can just
take the free night but you forgot about
Star Wars use the forks use the forks do
it
Queen d4 check forking the king in the
night no okay so actually I wasn't
threatening the play Bishop to d2 but he
helped me he played d4 no no because
that made no sense what you said we were
analyzing Bishop to d2 so the bishop
would not take the Queen right yeah
that's right okay so he played d4 and
now he can't do any of that because he
can't take his own pawn now I'm ready to
checkmate him checkmate is good what
vitamin does it have vitamin C for
checkmate okay aren't you glad you got
that yeah three of you got there okay
now the reason 3.14 didn't get it is
because oranges aren't pies right
well maybe okay my opponent was greedy
so he played Queen c2
so to capture the center pond and also
his rooks going to capture this blonde
he's using the forks now
what's better a center pawn or a side
pawn all right let's go back to the
plane and earth what's the right answer
the center so I saved my sin upon by
playing Bishop f4 he could still take my
setter pawn but that would be risky okay
so instead he played rook takes a two
now my bishops on the proper diagonal so
I played rip d2 getting rid of his queen
treating the rooks and then Queen h4 I'm
cold
good now there's no defense to his h6
pawn her a such a razor hit raise your
hand yeah
raise your hand okay you his bishops
defending it but I got two guys on him
he's only got one guy defending it who
gets the prize for raising their hand
you the King can go to g7 that's the one
o'clock class because my pawn could take
him you meant h7 right that's what you
meant now I'm going to show you
something so complicated you needed an
advanced degree in hyperbolic topology
to understand it after King h7 watch
this trick I have it's not really a
trick it's just a simple trick I can
take his pawn what would he do take my
bishop then I put him in check
and boom goes the dynamite
now his King moves I take with
unstoppable checkmate so he didn't like
that I liked it
no talking what she raise your hand
don't raise your hand all right
so he didn't play King age seven he
could also play g5 then I take you take
I take and here comes our good friend
Queen age seven mate
isn't he a good friend he's my friend
he's not my opponent's friend okay he
could also play h5 then I would play g4
that if he takes it our good friend
queen h7 mate is coming is he a good
friend okay so he's in a lot of trouble
he played Queen e2 a very sneaky move
very sneaky however I saw the movie mr.
deeds so I never underestimate the
sneaky why did you spit your drink out
at home you never even saw that movie no
you saw it okay so yeah I'm quoting Adam
Sandler I shouldn't be tiger okay now
let's play the obvious way and then
we'll see why it doesn't work this ship
takes pawn Bishop takes Bishop Queen
takes Bishop and now it looks like white
has unstoppable me but black played the
very sneaky Queen e2 earlier now he can
stop me
how does he stop it you correct what
taking the night that then me also I
could take his queen but you were 50%
right
Arjun who might have the right answer
who queen III check now I can't meet him
because the computer won't let me
because I'm in check so I have to trade
Queens which I don't want to do so
before I play Bishop takes pawn I played
an intermezzo as missions or as you
would say
I played rookie 1 now I don't think his
Queens going to e3 so he Chuck and I
took and here comes the checkmate cold
so he could have given up because I'm
going to check made him but my students
never give up so he sacrificed his
knight and I said thank you
I'm very polite then he attacked my ruck
and I put my knight I took his bishop
now if he plays Queen takes rook me it's
not me and if he plays King takes bishop
then it is me so he took with the rook
now some of you most of you especially
you at home you guys at home got to get
better ok after Queen h6 with
unstoppable me right
it is unstoppable mate except I'm the
one getting mated Queen takes rook me I
get made it before he does so is that
what I did
now I played Knight f3 defending my rock
nice and safe also if he had a free move
he could play Queen d2 and stop my Queen
from going to age 6 now he can't play
Queen d2 because my knight defends it so
he can't stop Queen h6
my rooks defended I have another way to
mate too if you don't like this way I
got this way Knight g5 Queen age 7 May
so now that he's down at night and I'm
going to checkmate him what did he do he
resigned right and then and then I
looked on my phone and Michigan lost by
like 30 points sad right then what
happened the following week
Michigan State beat Iowa like at the end
of the game come on
aren't you guys paying attention the Big
Ten championship all right now as I was
explaining being a professional players
fun you win all your games then the last
round when you're playing for a prize
you lose that you get no prize so I'm
playing in the last round and I'm
playing a national mastered a Knick
Carlo his rating is 2250 is that higher
than you that's higher than you by about
2150 okay and am i higher than him or
lower well one of you was right yeah
2600 is still higher than 2250 until the
new math comes into effect so I need to
win and I'll win some money if I don't
want I want anything now we played a
very funny game I thought it was funny
my opponent thing was so funny the
reason it was funny is after 20 moves
nothing was traded okay so it was really
boring he wanted to play boring and hope
that it would be a draw because then I
wouldn't win okay so nothing happened
nothing happened it's like The Blair
Witch Project nothing happens okay all
right now something happened
I played Bishop h6 because I want to
play f4 rawr and he played 9 to f1 so
when I play half four and he takes it
his knights defending III so I can't
play e3 so I prepared F form where I
played g5 and I won on the Kings side
and he won on the Queen side that was
very exciting it's exciting because we
didn't trade anything and then all of a
sudden everybody took everything it got
all crazy the mood all changed right I
prepared for this game with Eminem right
I did if I played n peanut yeah ok so he
played c4 and as you know c4 is well
explosive is the right word but your
jokes slightly less funny ok we could
say if you like the move that move is to
bomb we could say that
okay so yeah we get another joke in
there that's good all right
so I played f4 and he played c5 sort of
a mirror image have we traded anything
yet
no all the pieces are on the board I
have a King side attack and he has a
queen side attack for example it was his
move he would win a piece right away
what would he do if it was his move if
it was White's move why can win a free
piece if you're taking notes winning a
free piece is good I'm talking to you
Rick you with the possibly right answer
but I doubt it his queen could take this
pawn very risky it does fork the Queen
in the bishop
well you might lose your queen it is a
fork but it's the wrong fork so what you
do is you eat from the outside in
where's the inside out at a dinner party
that we're using the right fork you
would know that which way outside in
right yeah yeah that's the right fork
Arjen you are right over there you asked
you did for the answer Arjen correct
yeah see six forking my bishop and
Knight
do I want to lose my bishop or Knight
now so I played Bishop to d5 then he
attacked my Bishop but I saw it have we
traded a lot of pieces so far okay now
during this game I was thinking
something something my opponent wasn't
thinking okay and it's rated G so I can
tell you but the ones I could tell you
his thinking during the game that was
rated G so during the game I was
thinking of Karpov Kasparov 24th game of
their match Karpov was up 12 to 11
so if Karpov Windsor draws he's the
world champion if Gaspar off wins it's
12 12 and he was the champion he retains
his title
this was their third or four
match so you might think gopher check me
if you check me you win cuz sprog didn't
do that cuz farah didn't do anything he
moved around in a circle and hypnotized
his opponent he one of the games ago a
million moves the longer the game goes
the more likely his opponent make a
mistake at some point if you play a
hundred moves you might make some
mistakes if you play four moves you
could only make four mistakes and most
of you would okay so I thought if the
game went on and on and on and on he
would have make a mistake eventually
just like Karpov did because spar off
won that game and retained his title now
we've had no trades were moving around
and around and around trying to get an
advantage and finally when we started
capturing things then he made mistakes
because he was getting low on time so he
took something I took back and he played
rook c1 getting the open file and I
didn't like my king here because he
might check me so I moved it to the
corner where it's safe
my opponent took and I took and he made
a move that's so scary that even if
you're not afraid of zombies you'll be
afraid of this move he played queen c6
notice the queen is attacking the knight
which is not protected and it's
attacking the rook that's not protected
well that Knights protected a lot I'm
not worried about that so he's using the
forks because Star Wars is coming out
soon right how did I save my knight and
my rook luckily there's like five
answers you with the right answer right
now both my Knights can go to f6 but you
meant the correct one because the
incorrect one would lose my rook right
if you move this one then he just takes
my rock but if I move the correct one
now my rook is defending the other rook
and my Knights defending my knight and
my Knights defending my pawn wasn't that
lucky okay so I could also play Knight
c7 but that would be passive Knight f6
is because I'm going to checkmate him
right now he attacked
the queenside that was very scary no I
wasn't scary okay now he broke a very
important rule but I don't blame him
because he's playing me so it's tough
I'm going to push all my puns on the
kingside west burger style rawr he
doesn't want me to do that so he played
g4 blocking the Kings side okay and
since your kids you don't know the young
pissant reward didn't talk about that
yeah now I play Queen e6 with a devilish
trap which he missed it's good that he
missed it okay although computer says
I'm winning anyway because look at his
bishop boo terrible okay so now I have a
threat but he didn't see the threat so
that didn't work out he played Knight G
- now who knows what a skewer is guess Q
R is when you attack a piece and a
smaller piece behind it okay so if I
played rook c8 that would be a skewer
tagging the Queen and the rook the
problem with that skewer is his rooks
defended so he just loses Queen why
however if his rook was off the board
now rook C it would be really good right
rook c8 wins everything so I want his
rook away from his other rook how do I
make this rook move away from this rock
partial credit I want this truck to move
so I can play rook c8 and take his rook
you with the right answer how do I know
that you know the right answer right
knight to be four right okay so he's
like thanks for the free night now I can
attack his Queen either way one ways
right and one ways wrong
the problem with this move is he can
stay on my other rook and now if I take
his rook he takes my rug so that doesn't
work
I
to play the rook on a to ca and now I'm
going to take his rook and everybody's
happy when I say everybody I be me now
it turns out Nik Carlo my opponent was
supposed to move to Nebraska for medical
school okay
and I said where are you gonna move to
Nebraska that's true by the way
and he said crazy town I'm like crazy
town and he's like I know crazy town
that's where my people are right Nik
Carla lives in crazy town right so yeah
that's a real place crazy town okay
and also Danny wrench lives there he's
the head of chess calm okay so when you
live in crazy town you make some crazy
moves right you guys don't live in crazy
town so you would move your queen right
live in crazy town you give away your
queen so he played pawn takes pawn and I
took his Queen asked me why I gave his
Queen away you're not even asking you to
tell me why such a simple answer such a
long explanation
what's the simple answer lives in crazy
town
hi so he'd rather lose a queen for a
ruck than lose a whole Rock I'm like all
right
now I attacked his rook and he saw it
and I attacked his other rook this pawn
is a text so many times I can't even
count that high
so if he saves his rook I'm gonna it's
at least three I'm going to take this
pawn a million different ways now when I
played this way I was analyzing pawn
takes pawn Knight takes rook attacking
his rook rook takes pawn attacking my
Queen defended by the bishop Queen f7
threatening to destroy his world rook f6
and finally I saw Queen a - the idea is
if he takes my bishop I take his rook if
he takes my rook I take his rook if he
takes my bishop this way that's why I
play Queen A - BAM
yeah well I'll check me soon okay so
that was what I was expecting but he
didn't do that he played f5 that's a
better move I took his rook he took and
now the F files not open I can't
checkmate his King so I moved my queen
he took my bishop and I took his pawn
now let's see who's good at counting
what's the material situation I have a
queen for a bishop Knight and upon
everything else is the same
what's worth more a queen or a bishop
Knight and upon what's worth more yes
close I'll give you one more guess queen
okay
now if you did your math yesterday I
assume you'll have your math homework
I'll collect at the end of class Queen
is worth nine right if you don't agree
with that and you speak German it's
still nine doesn't matter and a Bishop
Knight in a pawn are worth seven if you
did some kind of crazy math so Queens
worth more than a bishop Knight and pawn
also I'm going to play 93 attacking f2
and I'm going to try to Queen this pawn
when I say I'm going to try to Queen it
I did Queen it so I must have worked out
okay he played rookie six not a good
move but it has a very good threat who's
the smartest distt what is white
threatening to do Rickie's six has a
really mean threat if you don't see it
you got another one o'clock class what
what is white threatening to do Arjun
this should be five forks my queen and
king then I would lose and I cry because
then no prize money so I played nine to
d3 which does two things at once it
protects your Bishop e5 and it threatens
your f2 also does a third thing it lets
my pawn promote my knight was in front
of my pawn that's not he stopped Queen
f2 and I was like oh boy
I can promote my pawn but then I
remembered that I'm a grandmaster I was
like nah I'm a grandmaster I almost
forgot that for a second okay
grandmasters don't let their opponents
do stuff my opponent wants to play
Bishop e5 check and win my queen that
means my knight can't move anywhere if
my knight moves up like a shaggy five
check and win my queen right so I was
like why is my King in the corner on the
same color as his bishop so I played
King GA now if I wasn't a grandmaster I
would just Queen my pawn and win quicker
but as a grandmaster have to stop all
tricks you know why I stopped all tricks
Arjun come on I told this joke for four
years come on then Simon tricks are for
kids
okay so I play King g8 now he could
never even check me okay so now I'm
trying to Queen my be pawn successfully
I might add I did pretty good didn't I
now he played for one last trick he
checked me but I saw I was in check
pretty good huh yeah and I move my king
now if he plays Bishop e5 check I'll
take it with my knight I'm serious but
if my knight was off the board then he
would play Bishop e5 check and win even
though he's down a queen because I would
be in checkmate soon so how does he get
rid of my knight easy yeah rook g3 took
my knight now most of you would take the
rook and then you get checkmated then I
would lose that he gets my prize money
so did I take the rook and get
checkmated now I defended the e5 square
so you can't do that and I did something
really really really really good it's
the third best thing you could do in
chest
the best thing is checkmate the second
best thing is to take a queen this is
the third best you yeah I made a queen
and before that happened I looked on the
side of the board to see their extra
Queens and there were now I have two
extra Queens and I stopped checkmate
with my queen and I'm threatening to
take this and this so with the two extra
Queens and forced checkmate he did what
any chess master would do he resigned
and then what did I do get the prize
money the best answer today
I might not play good chess but I'm
going to get in the prize money yeah I
get that prize money so I didn't play
chess for six months but I still didn't
lose any games I still got my prize
money okay then he went home crying